unbelievable record donations I can't
take you enough jack
I'm gonna be on the vineyard next month
I want you and Tracy to come up and
we'll talk about getting you back in the
movie business I'll set that up sir okay
Tracy bring your daughter that's the
deal
thanks again Joe congratulations Tracy
and welcome to the grown-up world yeah I
don't have a daughter
let's have a casting session on Monday
dumb Jack your dog how are ya and good
sir
course you are look at those eyes sharp
like a Panthers
thank you sir we'd like to sit down I
can't I took my grandkids snorkeling
save bars got stung by jellyfish I got a
welt on my ass the size of a Red
Delicious apple I'm very sorry to hear
that sir
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you how's the heart holding that
buddy know you ought to just quit guys
loves quitters if I understood his
autobiography correctly oh wait I didn't
you know what it's all right jack
when you're dead and I'm CEO how do you
do it you're always in such great shape
same weight as win arrest of the Yale
Jack what's up I wrestled at Yale
what other dude thanks this is he
continued your bag is like a barrel of
snakes oh I think I love you
we're joking so how's the ticker Devon
told me he said you're not a well man
well why don't we forget about Devon for
the moment are you concerned about my
heart sir no not at all not after today
you were out there with those boys and
your conditions you talk about heart
take care of yourself jack
I've technically died twice it's not fun
but I'm not gonna be around forever at
some point I want to spend more time
with my grandkids take my boat down to
the island say get to know my secret
family up in Canada but I want you to
know you're on my list Jack you might
run this company one day thank you sir
[Music]
you might have have what you eat there
mr. Geiss I'm so sorry I just found out
that you're here I'd have my assistant
sit on his naughty stool if he didn't
love it so much
no apologies I'm just admiring your bulb
cover thank you sir
are you all right that's the diabetes
I'm lightheaded all the time I can't see
a damn thing we're all getting older sir
tell me about it
my baby girl was getting married she and
her fiance are out choosing floral
arrangements right now Fire Island
really I'd love to come out might the
surf together
light a fire check each other for ticks
Kathy I think I just found the perfect
place for our honeymoon you're getting a
fine son-in-law sir Thanks would do
anything for the company I know there's
no love lost between you and Devon
you're both been competing for my job
for almost a year
hang in there while so many others
cracked under the pressure like Bob
Duncan the head of the stress ball
division hanged himself now it's come
down to you and banks this decision was
not easy jack banks is joining my family
they had a Stan sir but I'm not running
a family I'm running a business so I'm
going with you congratulations you're
going to run this company all right yeah
get one crying life you've chosen well
when will this be made public sir how
about my mother didn't know before she
dies so she goes to her grave a defeated
woman well only the two of us can know
now I've got to present it to the board
you've got to get your successor in
place I've got a shortlist ready well
word of advice whoever you choose it's
got to be someone you trust I guess that
rules out the Federal Reserve
[Laughter]
Don I'd like you to meet Liz Lemon
aren't you the gal who pioneered the
button classic campaign that was me what
the hell is Donna you've been hiding you
owe my blood sugar is dropping please
sweetie can you run out to the dessert
table and get me something oh sure but
you should know that I work for tips
ah you've got the charm and spark of a
young Leona Helmsley what's wrong with
him leo well to the untrained eye he'd
appear to be what we in the medical
community call it sleeping but he is in
fact in a diabetic coma which she could
have been avoided by what we call eating
do whatever you can leo okay this is the
gross part
[Music]
that shot was just a placebo I was
hoping this was psychological
it may not be faking it for attention
Jack have you seen done oh boy that
doesn't look good
don't panic Jorgenson it's under control
he just has to say one sentence couldn't
you just you know inject something right
into his heart love to but we have no
way of knowing where the heart is see
every human is different Jake it's okay
Don isn't feeling well he's in a
diabetic coma my possibly faking how did
this happen it was Jorgensen's fault
fair enough it's all right I'm in charge
now
you see yesterday I met with Don and he
said I'm going to become a successor so
I'm the CEO Jack if this is a power grab
it's in very bad taste no no he said it
he told me to keep it a secret no it's
true I heard it secondhand from Jack
okay thanks thanks knows he can back me
up Jack Jack I don't know what you're
talking about
Oh daddy
and at four one one and nine one one New
York diabetes repair I guess Cathy you
are doing the job of the CEO should be
you on the cover of the quarterly report
it will be if Cathy's father ever comes
out of his coma until then the board has
put her in charge and we need to respect
that
what does something happen to her
something bad then we would have a
secret that bound us together what is
she doing I don't know
whether a weather event is approaching
or hit me Jack Donaghy mr. Geiss it is
very good to see you up and about sir
yeah Jackie boy I think you know why
you're here congratulations you are the
first to know
officially that I'm staying on as CEO
I'm sorry what do you see a beam of
energy came and spoke to me during my
coma no I don't know what it was it
could have been an alien maybe it was
God maybe it was an unborn Aztec King
but it told me my work here is not yet
done it's done I think it's done you're
still my choice to take over when I die
if that ever even happens
[Music]
hello if you're watching this you are an
executive of the General Electric
Corporation and the unthinkable is
happening
capitalism is ending either because of
the Soviets or something ridiculous like
a woman president god he looks so young
I was speaking to you in the year 1987
but my message is timeless avoid the
noid we've all worked hard but now it's
over
there's only one thing for you to do go
to your loved ones hold them close
because in the end and if you're
watching this it is the end love is all
that matters
[Music]
you